七海
一という言葉を聞いたら皆さんどのようなことを思い出しますか
おそらく多くの人たちにとって波というものはネガティブなものではないでしょうか
しかしこの悩みという言葉僕にとってとても大切なものなんです
今日は僕の悩みについて少し話させてください
おそらく多くの人たちを悩ませてきて質問って必ずありますよね
僕は小さい頃お母さんが好き
お父さんが好きどっちかしか選べなかったらどっちを選ぶ
て質問が実は部材質も生浜んでした
それから僕を困らせました
でもそれ以上に僕を困らせてきた質問があります
それはこれです
あなたは何人なの
僕は23年前韓国のソウルで観光人の父と日本人の母の間で生まれました
母の判断によって僕は韓国と日本
2つの国籍を持つ二重国籍者として生まれました
そして生後6ヶ月の赤ん坊の頃
僕は親の仕事の関係で初めて飛行機に乗せん
中国まで飛んでいきました
そうやって私たち家族の中国の生活が始まりました
中国の生活は僕にとって初めての海外生活とも言えますが
僕は初めて学んだ言葉も中国をであり
そして初めて受けた教育も中国であり
ん
そして中国の食べ物を食べながら中国の子どもたちと同じように遊びながら育ちました
そう言って僕は
可能に
中国の子供になっていました
しかし父は大
これはまずいと思っていたようですなぜならほか中国は中国の子供のように抜けました
が自分の母国である韓国と日本は前月を喋れなかったのです
お前のルーツを知るべきだという父の言葉とともに私たちは家族は韓国に戻ることに
なりました
そう言って僕は韓国で中学校通い始めます
しかし他何か違和感を感じてしまったんです
韓国で生活が始まったら僕は体を韓国にいるが心は長年暮らしてきた
中国から離れられませんでした
そして何か属していのような気分がしました
また母が日本人だということで僕は多文化家庭
子女と
指定されていました
当時韓国が年々外国から嫁入りする外国人が特に東南アジアから増えて来て見た目の
違いや言葉の不自由さによって差別をされることが問題視されていてそれを防ぐために
多文化家庭政策というのを行っていました
そのせいか放課後ほか担任の先生から呼ばれ
言えるちゃんと韓国を学んでいるかとか
学校でいじめられてないかと長々と質問を受けまくりました
そして
僕は思いました
お父さんどうして怒って僕の国なんじゃないん
何もでも大変だったのは勉強でした
韓国はでは中学校に入ったらもう激しい競争
学歴競争社会に入っていて
勉強がすごく厳しかった
ちゃんと韓国で教育を受けたことがなかった僕がいきなり飛び込ん組むのもなかなか
簡単なことではありませんでした
周りのクラスメイトたちも必死に大学という目標に向けて走っていました
僕も何がなんだか分からずとにかく頑張って走っていました
そしてある日ふと思いました黒一体何でこんな
頑張っているんだろうそしてこの橋と先にやって何があるんだろう
答えがわからなくなった僕は周りの大人たちにその
灯油をすると
このようなことをしました
あなた大きくなったら立派な外交官になるか
あなた大きくなったら立派な弁護士になるかあなた大きくなった
それからお医者さんになるであろうか
今頑張って勉強して良い大学に行きなさいと
お花育て周りの人たちが夢であるべきと話している事柄に反してどれ一つも自分を
当てはめることができませんでした
翼を考えるとか夢の為なんかより
別に夢のために頑張って行けたわけではなくとにかく普通じゃないとみられるのが怖く
て
普通の韓国の学生に頑張ってなろうとしていたのです
こんな頑張ったのが先が普通の韓国尖閣を学生になろうとしていただけだったのか
何か虚しく思ってしまいました
その時ボカ自分のもう一つのルーツである
日本へ行ってみようじゃないかと思い始めました
これまで僕は日本で暮らしたことはありませんが
日本国籍があるということで僕は被告市場という枠で大学に入ることができました
ほか観光の経験から
普通の日本人僕がなることもまあ
できないようなと思いました
でも幸いなことに
僕と似たような日本国籍を持っているが海外で育った日国市場という仲間がたくさん
できたことで僕はあああ
普通じゃなくてもいいんだなと思えるようになってきました
そしておかわりにに国籍と自由化
柵からを少し自由になって
自分は自分だと思えるようになっていました
それが僕が自己紹介するときはとか
中国で育った日本と韓国のハーフですとか何人かを問われたときは僕は
東アジア人ですと答えていました
そしてその同時に僕はまた一方デー
国とか国籍とかには関係なく世界のために働く
国際公務員になって4をために働けばいいんじゃないかという憧れの夢も実は膨らませ
ていました
そうしたある日
僕にこれが届きました
国籍選択と武家というものです
今届けは
ここみたいの二重国籍を持っている人がまあ22歳になる前までにどちらかの国籍を
選ばなければいけないということを意味していました
そう言って結局あなたはない子になるの
この質問国という存在からもされるようになりました
ちょうどその頃韓国は国籍法が変わって二重国籍を認めるようになりましたが
韓国の兵器に入って来ないだ
全体に行ってきてけじめをつけないと韓国の国籍を放棄するのも認めてくれない
いいました
そして日本には日本で二重国籍が認めないと
そのように
外国の軍隊など公的機関が日本国籍を持っていると言ってはいけないというのです
他2つの
国の国籍を持つことで2つの国の制度の狭間でどうしようもできないような状態に陥っ
ていました
他混乱しました
なぜならその時
二どっちかの国籍を選ばないと自分やと夢だとに思っていた
国際公務員も慣れないということを知りました
そしてどっちか選べという子ことにことを置い責められ
また放置込めました
どっちも属さない自分属せない自分は
積極世界から受け入れられないんだなっ
そして国や周りや社会が望む答えを出せない僕あ
存在価値もね厄介な奴なんじゃないかと
僕はたくさん悩んだ仲
この悩みからまた逃げたいとも思いました
なぜなら寂しかったからです
そうですこの悩みは周りから結局アナとはない子になって問われた時
そのために対して人たちが望む答えはできなかったことなんです
あれが当たり前と思うことが当たり前じゃなかった
滑稽健はさみしい経験でした
こんな悩みなんか人によってもわたってくれないでしょ
思ってしまってい
3桁勝った悩みですがでも
僕はこの悩みから絶対に逃げないと思う
きっかけがありました
無国籍者たちとの出会いでした
無国籍者等
国籍をというステータスを持っていない
つまりどこの国からも国民として認められていない
そのような状態に人たちを意味します
その人たちの存在は僕は大学2年生の時図書館で偶然手に取った
この無国籍という本を通じて知ることになりました
是非この本の作者に会ってみたいなと思い
そう思ってた時にちょうど大阪でシンポジウムが行われてそこで僕はその作者に会う
ことができたです
その方はこの写真の左側に写っていして実は今日この前もご来場いただいているナラ
さんです
皆さんはご自身が無国籍者だった経験を通じて
無国籍のストーリーテーリングを行いこの問題を知らせていきたい
の国籍という恭文にある人たちの支援活動を行っていました
北アラーさんとの出会いを通じて
日本にもたくさんの方国籍者がいると
そして国籍というステータスがないことによって
海外ところができなかったいっ
あるいは結婚ができなかったよ
あるいはこの世の中に存在しない人として扱われてしまったりする境遇の中にいる人
たちと出会うことができました
しかしそのように世の中から否定されている中
僕はであった次の方々は
いきいきと自分の人生を歩んでいました
春ミャンマーの報告席車
大学生でしたが
同期が海外修学旅行に行くとき一緒に行けなかったり
大学の奨学金がもらえなかったり
たくさんの壁にぶち当たっていました
しかし
彼はこう言いました
海外旅行がいいに行けなくても僕は月島
ナンバーよりも国内旅行を楽しんでやるとか
奨学金がもらえなくても自分が好きのアルバイトをやり続けて勉強を続けると語ってい
ました
何かしみじみと心の中に入ってきました
たとえ
世の中が存在を否定したからといっても
自分は自分を信じる
その姿を一生僕はは崩れてはいけないと思いました
たとえ
周りが望む答え答えられなくても
有賀飲んでいるようにどこか国あ場所に根づかなくても
僕は自分自身は答えに根付きたいと
思い始めました
そして
この悩みは必ずどこかでまた分かち合える人たちがいるはずだから
そしてまた同じくどこかで寂しい思いをしている人たちがいるはずだから
コーナー3から絶対に入れたくないと思いました
そしてこの悩みをどんどんまた世界ぶつけて行きたいと思いました
大学3年生の頃他
香港に留学をしていたのですがちょうどその時
中国政府に対して
香港では激しい民主化運動がコップとしていました
僕の本校の友達も
毎日のように中心街に出て
座り込みをしてデモに参加していました
がいったいどのようなことがどのようなきっかけで彼のそのような熱気のある行動に3
つ導いているか
おった気になり帰ってご飯を食べながら聞いてみると彼はここに悩みを言ってくれまし
た
っからこう言いました
自分が生まれ育ったこの香港大切に思う
そして親から与えられたって自分が享受してきたこの自由6
すごく大切にもでもなんだか今それが失われようとしているんだと
よく自分もわかっていないかもしれないけどそれが僕は怖いんがぁ
その気持ちを伝えていかないと誰もわかってくれないんだと
おそらく
僕は彼と生まれ育った場所も違う
こうやって彼らに話を聞いていなかったら
抱えていたその悩みも
は体で一生過ごしていただろうと思いました
世の中に沢山自分が知らない場所でこのように悩み必死に向き合っている人たちがいる
だろうなと思い
ば是非まずその人たちの存在を知らなければいけないと知りたいと思いました
世界約90架空以上から4 s 2000人の
若き活動家たちが集まる完顔ゴーあるとというサミットに参加出る
できる機会がありました
そこでも僕は自分の悩みを空けていきたいとおもい
そしたら
またたくさんの bear in 巡り会えました
そこには
北朝鮮から自由を求めて脱北したがその過程で親をしない
そして家族とバラバラいない
それでも自由を追い求めて続けている
脱北者の少女がいました
そこには
南アフリカの小さな村で生まれ
恵まれてない環境で生まれたと馬鹿にされ続けたかそれでも夢があれば何でも成し遂げ
られることを証明するために
自分で加工立てたい本を書いたりしながら啓蒙活動を行っている
ある生命がいました
そこには世界で最も人口の多い無国籍民族とも言われる
くる同然出身でありながら
周りで居場所を失ってしまったシリア並みのために支援活動を行っている
友人ができました
それぞれ異なるバックグラウンド中
異なる意見も確かにたくさんありましたが僕はその違いというよりか何かは価値ある
共通点に目がいきました
それは
それぞれ異なる悩みを抱い引いて
その異なるねぇ向き合うことでさらに自分たちのモチベーションになっているという
ことです
この最初は大見てもわからないであろうという悩みでしたが
向き合っているうちにイ
分かち合える人たちができていきました
そしてその悩みに向き合っていることで
その人たちから
元気をもらったという声をいただきました
気づけばそれは僕のとっても大きな幸せ
そして生きがいになっていたのです
皆様も一人ひとり異なる悩みを抱えていると思います
しかしそのことで悩みがあるからこそそこから生まれる異なる答えが合っ
そのことに異なる答えがまた皆それぞれ違う
異なる人生を描いていけるようにするのではないでしょうか
そして僕はこれらの経験から3つのけ3つのことを教えてもらいました
まず
自分の悩みに向き合うことで
自分の心の中にある答えに近づけること
してこの答えを信じてみることで
悩みは原動力になり得る
そして悩みを原動力に変えられたとき
それはもう悩みではなく
とか
生きている意味だと思えるようになったということです
皆さんは一人一人
その悩みというものがいい
どんな小さな悩みでも
それは屋はなここの中には大切な悩みだと僕は思います
どんな小さな悩みでもそれに向き合っている時間が周りから無駄立を言われても
僕はその波向き合っている姿を是非応援していきたいです
なので是非皆様の話もろくに聞かせてください
今日ご静聴ありがとうございました